I honestly really really didn't want to
have to do this
Rachel Lindsay went live on Instagram
Sunday afternoon to speak on Hannah
Browns apology for singing the n-word
it's easy to make a statement it's easy
to hide behind words but when you're
bold enough to say the n-word on camera
on your platform then you need to be
bold enough to use your face and you're
on camera and apologize in the same way
that you set the word Rachel made it
clear that she was personally offended
by Hannah's actions and she felt the
need to speak out publicly after
reaching out to Hannah personally I
thought you know what let me just speak
to the person directly and let them know
how I'm feeling you know it's not an
opportunity to call somebody out it's
not necessarily an opportunity to drag
someone it's an opportunity to maybe
educate them to speak to them about how
you were personally upset about it so
that's exactly what I did never with the
intention to come to an Instagram live
never in the tension with the intention
to call someone out I thought let me
challenge this person to use their
platform because last night it was used
in a different way so let me challenge
them to use it in a better way right
maybe it was a mistake maybe they didn't
realize the intention behind it so let
me give them opportunity to now use
their platform to correct that mistake
according to Rachel that challenge was
not met by Hannah now I understand that
an apology was made but when I know what
could have been done what I know what I
challenged someone to do they refused to
do it or they did not do it I should put
it that way they did not do it this all
comes after this video of Hannah singing
the babies rock stars went viral I know
I'm a guinea
you can [ __ ] [ __ ] with it still on my
back on my cup have you ever seen a real
hot stock it's Duncan guitars and Stroke
fans were quick to call the former
Bachelorette out for using the n-word
after Hannah caught wind of what
happened she seems to alternate between
apologizing blaming it on her brother
and saying she never used the n-word I
did I'm so sorry
that wasn't you that was
though I was singing this I'm so sorry I
don't think I mean no there's it is
Patrick anyway well just say that word
my cousin killer so know what stay here
I said whatever I did on Sunday
afternoon she posted an apology to her
Instagram story saying quote I owe you
all a major apology there is no excuse
and I will not justify what I said I
have read your messages and seen the
hurt I have caused I own it all I am
terribly sorry and I know that whether
in public or private this language is
unacceptable I promise to do better that
word as many was used to make black
people feel less than it was used to
make them feel inferior and every time
you use that word and you aren't black
you give that word power and that is why
that is wrong Rachel gave further
context to why the word should be
avoided even if it's in a song I was
talking to a friend today and they make
this comment the word [ __ ] used to be
so a word that nobody nobody could use
right it was so vile to use that against
a woman and then women start to take
power back over the word and they call
each other hey [ __ ] what's up [ __ ]
they say it all the time if a man went
around calling to woman a woman a [ __ ]
we would be all up in arms because it is
not okay for him to do that you see
women doing that because they're taking
power back in the world Rachel who is
the first and only black lead in
bachelor franchise history wasn't the
only one to speak out against Hannah's
behavior Becca Martinez took to her
Instagram stories saying in part quote
how are people still gonna defend celebs
with access to so much privilege
knowledge and education saying the
n-word even if it's just the lyrics to a
song Nick Viall also took
Instagram stories saying quote there is
no excuse period super sad and
disappointing to see I repeat non black
people should not feel okay about saying
the word it's wrong you wouldn't say it
on TV you wouldn't say it on the radio
you wouldn't say it in front of your
black friend and if the reason that you
wouldn't say that is because you feel
uncomfortable then maybe you shouldn't
say it in private around your other
friends either maybe you shouldn't sing
along with it to a song Rachel ended her
Instagram live by calling on everybody
to do better and be better if you're
going to praise someone for being open
and sincere and being honest and being
so upfront and and and bold and speaking
out then you have to hold them
accountable when they don't do it over a
controversial situation a controversial
situation when it's controversy that
they caused
[Music]